>>Ann Doyle: Hello. I'm Ann Doyle. I'm the
author of "Powering Up: How America's Women
Achievers
Become Leaders", and I've been invited here
to Google's headquarters in Ann Arbor to participate
in
your Authors, is that what you call it?
>>Female in audience:#1: MmmHmm.
>>Ann Doyle: Kind of an author's forum, which
I really appreciate. I'm a Michigan person.
So, and I'm a
graduate of the University of Michigan. So,
this is kind of home here in Ann Arbor. But
I'm going to talk
just a little bit about what the books about,
what motivated to write it, and what I-I-I
hope a reader will
get out of picking this book up. And then
I would love you to ask me some tough questions.
I was a
journalist for 15 years and made a good part
of my career. I made a pretty good living
asking really
difficult questions. So, I hope you'll do
that, and I'll begin by just saying that I
am a woman who is, I'm-
I've been a professional woman for 40 years.
And so I-I have seen tremendous change in
my adult
lifetime in terms of what's happened in the
work place in terms of women. And so, and
because I was
a woman who was really part of that generation
that was really on the cutting edge in terms
of pushing
the edges of women moving into a really nontraditional
jobs. I-I-I-I did those things myself, and
I also
was a journalist who covered all that. And
so I really was very, very close to what happened,
and how
far we've come as women, and also really conscious
about how far we still have to go.
And so I really got to a point in terms of
after all this period of time where I, people
always said to me,
"Ann, you know, you really oughta write a
book." Because my background includes 15 years
as a
journalist, where one, five years I spent
as one of the first woman TV sports broadcasters
in the
nation. So I helped to open the locker rooms
in this country, the sport's locker rooms.
And so I call that
a leadership laboratory where you are tested
in some pretty tough environments.
Then I spent the second part of my careers
at Ford Motor Company, and the auto industry
has a pretty
famous steel ceiling, as I call it. So, you
know, I had the corporate experience of understanding
what it
takes to, for women to push, raise that ceiling,
uh, which are very much still in place in
the
corporate environment.
I'm also a single parent. I-I have a 19 year
old son. I would call parenting a leadership
laboratory. His
father died when he was very, very young.
So I pretty much raised him by myself. And
then the
fourth piece of really what I bring to this
conversation is I ran for office last year.
I've always been out there encouraging women
to run for office. We do not have enough women
running for office, and I'm part of something
called the "White House Project," which is
training. We
plan to train 35 thousand women by 2014 to
run for office. And someone finally said to
me, "Ann,
you're always telling everybody else to run,
why don't you stick your neck out there?"
So, I did that,
too.
So, I bring all of that experience to this
conversation, but when I finally decided that
I was going to write
a book, I knew that it wasn't, it shouldn't
just be memoir. This is not memoir. You know,
I have some
pretty great stories, and I-my stories are
woven through this book. But I knew that this-
this country at
this point is really just loaded with incredible
women who can match me story for story. And
so I put
on my journalist hat and I went looking for
the story. What's the story now? In 2011,
what's the story
now? And I interviewed 125 of the most incredible
women, the leaders from all different professions,
from all different generations, all different
races and cultural backgrounds not only from
the United
States but also from other parts of the world.
And-and the question was asking women from
other
parts of the world was, "What's your message
for American woman?" Because this is really
about
women; how women become leaders in our culture.
But I wanted the global perspective on that,
and
so, the good news is that I could have gone
on interviewing incredible, high-achieving
women for
years. I mean, this country is-has become
a nation of women achievers, and it's happened
in my adult
lifetime. And it's really incredible to see.
And there are now three very, very distinct
generations of high achieving women in the
workplace
today. And I write a chapter about each one
of these generations, because we're very,
very different.
And I think it's really important that we
start to understand each other, because there's
a lot of
dissonance between women. We're not helping
one another. And so, we're there in big numbers,
but
the story is that even though we become this
nation of high achieving women, we are leader
ship
underachievers. And some people really bristle
at that, you know. But, I mean the facts are
just
devastating in terms of proving that story,
and we hold an average of 18% of the leadership
positions
in every work sector. Now it has been 20 years
since men earned more college degrees than
women in this country. And that's a whole
other topic about what's going on with men.
But women have been
earning more college degrees for 20 years,
they're earning more graduate level degrees,
and they just
cracked more PhDs. So women are incredibly
qualified and the middle keeps getting bigger
and bigger
and bigger.
And it was very clear to me that women today
are, too few women are going anywhere that
women
haven't been before. And I really felt, that-it-and
I would say we've been stalled for at least
10 years,
maybe more. And there's sort of an unconsciousness
about it in terms of the importance of big
numbers of women moving up into those leadership
positions. And because I have the experience
as a
woman who, women of my generation who've really
moved into those non-traditional jobs, we
have
first, first, first all through our resumes.
Yet we were all alone when we were doing it.
But we also
knew we were part of something bigger than
ourselves, and so we knew we were like moving
women
forward in this country and we were. There's
no sense of that right now. I just don't see
enough
women daring to take the risk that it takes
to lead. And so, that's what this book is
about. That's what,
when I became very clear about what the story
was- is that we needed a book about graduate
work.
On what it takes for women, who are high achieving
women, highly educated, have mastered the
fundamentals of being successful, but-but
really needed almost like a field guide of
what the-what's
the graduate work? What do you do now? What's
next? If you really believe your leadership
material,
what is that working on? What are the skills
you need to have? And that's what this book
is about.
And those were the questions that I was asking
women. I have over 100 hours of transcribed
interviews with some of the most incredible
women. And one of the women right now, Major
General
Maggie Woodward is the person who is in charge
of the U. S., United States Air Operations
over Libya.
She made news a couple weeks ago because never
before has a woman commanded such a military
operation. And those were the ki- that's the
level of women that I had access to. And you
know, after
a while when you started doing all these interviews
and you start asking, you know, because I
wanted
to know, what do they know? I knew what I
know. I knew what I had learned over 40 years,
but I really
wanted to go hunting for, I knew there was
a tremendous amount of knowledge out there
and I
wanted to know what did they know? What did
they know that I didn't know? What did they
know
that we could pass on so that other women
wouldn't have to learn it one-by-one. You
know, I want
women to go faster. I want more women moving
into higher levels, aspiring higher, and I
want them
to go faster than we did. And so that's really
what I was looking for. And that's how I came
up with the
really, the second half of this book, I mean,
is the seven practices. I call it the "Seven
Practices." You
all have heard of Stephen Covey and his "Seven
Habits of Highly Effective People."
Well, this is- these are Seven Practices that
I say that high achieving women, who believe
they are
leadership material, this is what you need
to master next. And I didn't just make these
up. As I said,
they come from my experience, but they also
come from the themes that came through over
and
over and over again in these 100 hours of
transcripts. You know, and interviews that
I did with
incredible women. And I listed all the women
in the back of the book. You know, so you
could read
and see who these women are. And also on my
Facebook fan page, which is called "Powering
Up
Women Book" I think it is. But you can just
Google it, because it's a publ- you can just
Google it,
[laughter]
Because it's pub, because, I love how that's
become a verb, because it's a public site
now. But I've-I'm posting pictures of all
these women. You know, so that you can see
what they look like, and I'm asking these
women to give me not only like a professional
picture or kind of an office picture or head
shot. But I said give me an action picture.
You know, give me a shot of you doing your
work or, you know, with
your family or you know something that kind
of tells, shows somebody a little bit more
about to you.
And so you can look it up. They're right on
the fan page, and you can see Commander General
Maggie
Woodward with her paratroopers. You know,
she's a pilot. You know, that's her training
and
everything, right you know. And all their
flight gear in front of the plane. And those
kind of cool
pictures. So I listed all of them, but I will,
I guess I'll just mention, and then I hope
we can kind of have
a conversation here.
I divided the book into three parts, three
major parts. And the first major part is "Who
are we?" "Part
one: Who are we?" And that's where I basically
make my case that the first chapter is so
many
achievers, where are our leaders? You know
and I basic, that's where I make my case about
where we
are right now.
And then I have a chapter on each of these
three distinct generations of women, of high
achieving
women. And these are really subsets of the
generations. You know, we talk about baby
boomers and
gen Xs and new millennials. And I'm talking
about a subset of those groups. I'm talking
about women,
and I'm talking about aspiring women. And
that means women who are educated, usually.
They don't
have to be, but, you know. Are lucky enough
to be, you know, these are women who are struggling
to
survive usually. These are women lucky enough
to be in positions to start shaping our nation,
our
culture, our organizations. And so I divided
them into 3 groups and I named them. And nobody
else
has ever done this before, really named these
cohort groups. And I call them the interlopers,
that's
my generation. I call them the pioneering
interlopers. And if you know the definition
of interloper, the
dictionaries says," It's someone who imposes
herself or himself where they're not wanted
or in
other's business." So, you know, when I was
imposing myself and insisting on as a woman
journalist I
should have equal access to sports locker
rooms as the men who are going in there, I
was an
interloper. And so these women were very much
in situations like this. So I called them
the
pioneering interlopers. And we're in our mid
50s and older now. Geraldine Ferraro, we're
starting to
lose some of our interlopers. Geraldine Ferraro,
first woman ever to be on a national ticket
as Vice
President of the United States on the Democratic
ticket, just died of course, a pioneering
interloper.
The next generation are the women who are
really kind of mid-thirties up to early 50s,
and they are- I
call them the "influential insiders" because
they were very, very different from the interlopers.
Because while the interlopers needed certain
skills to- I mean really we were like fighting
our way in
the door. Nobody wanted us. We were fighting
our way in the door and ran into a lot of,
you know, a
lot of hostility even.
And this next genera- sometimes I call us
the marines. You know, we had to put on our
flak jackets
and really take some heavy fire right out
of college. And-and so we were kind of the
marines for
taking the professional beaches.
This next generation the "Influential Insiders,"
I really call them like the diplomats, because
they came
next, and they were, by the time they got
out of college and were moving into the workforce,
things
were changing. And the biggest thing that
changed was there was room for one woman.
They didn't
have to fight their way in the door. They
actually had, they were good. The ones who
are honest will
tell you it was an advantage to be a woman,
because, but there was only one woman. There
was
room for one woman, and so what happened was
it pitted women against one another. You were
competing with other women for the woman's
spot, the woman job. And so those women as
a group
tend not to be very supportive of other women,
because they were their primary competition.
The
other thing about them, they're the "I'm no
feminist but" women. I must have heard that
a million
times. They ran away from the whole thing
about feminism, because by that time feminism
had really
been changed in terms of its definition in
a lot of ways had been corroded and changed
from what I
understood it to be. And it really became
the "F" word in corporate America. It became
very
dangerous.
And they, the most successful "influential
insiders" were the ones who made it very clear
to the work
cultures they were in that they were not one
of those trouble-making interlopers. They
got along.
They're not boat rockers. And so that's characteristic
of this group, and it's not a criticism. It's
kind of
what they needed to do at that time. And they're
the women who had the opportunity to play
sports.
They're post title nine. They had some chances
to play sports. And I never had that chance
in high
School, in college. They are the first of
women to graduate from military academies.
So they are
more and more lawyers, more doctors, you know,
a very, very different group and a very important
group.
And now we come to probably most of you, who
are, I call you the "I'll do it my way innovators."
So
we have the interlopers, the insiders, and
the innovators. And I don't need to tell any
of you about all
the stuff that has been written about new
millennials and what you know about yourselves
in terms
of, I mean, I look around the room and just
look at the culture here at Google, which
is, you know, it's
fascinating. It-it's great. And even the way
you dress and the way you work and your expectations
about how you should be able to work are very,
very different and I think it's really very
exciting. And
you are the most educated and ambitious generation
of women in the history of the world. That's
just
a fact. And you know, we, American women,
are not ahead of women in other parts of the
world, but
there are several things that are different
about us. Number one, we are lucky enough
to be born into
the United States. One of the most influential
nations in the world and where we have legal
rights and
cultural rights; opportunities that women
all over the world just dream about. And so
it's just given.
And then the other huge piece of it is that
there are so many of us. You know, there's
no other nation
in the world, no one nation with so many highly
educated, economically- independent women
in the
world. You know until the potential of what
your generation can do and also, what these
three
generations of women can do in terms of shaping
the world that we live in is incredible. And
that-
that's what really has inspired me, because
I just see the table set. The table's just
set.
But I'm also very discouraged because I see
women standing at the gates of leadership
and - and
they're not pouring in. And it's really time
for women to start pouring into top leadership
the way I
witnessed women pouring in to non-professional
jobs in the 60s and the 70s. I saw it happen.
I know
what it feels like when you change a culture
dramatically. And you don't change culture
dramatically
with exceptions to the rule. You do it with
big numbers. And that's very much what I care
about. You
know I care about, and I feel very passionately.
I know that the world would be a better place
when
women are also- our voices and our experience
and our values are also at the table, you
know,
shaping decisions that are being made. Because
right now I kind of think of the human family
as sort
of, it's almost- most parts of the world it's
kind of a single father making all the decisions,
you know.
The mothers in terms of mothering leadership
at those decision making tables. Whether it's
political,
corporate, economic, cultural, all of those
things, every piece that shapes our culture,
our nation, our
world, the decisions that are made. Most of
those decisions are made by men. And, you
know what?
That's imbalanced. There's some really important
pieces that are missing, and I know we'll
make better
decisions when we get women. And women are
ready to be there.
So, that's pretty much is what my book is
about. And you know, one other thing I would
say about this is
that I like when I speak to women and I like
to say, you know, we're in a very steep learning
curve. because if you think about it, men
have been bred for leadership for thousands
of years. Thousands
of years and they have, they have millions
of models of men doing all these different
leadership,
taking all these different leadership roles
in every possible profession there is. And
women, number
one, were blocked out of all that. I mean,
it's all really very, very new in terms of
cultural evolution.
This is really pretty new stuff. We only started,
got the right to vote in 1920 in this country,
and really, I
mean, women couldn't even, you know, play
on; there were no sports teams for women when
I was
growing up. Until, you know, really mid-seventies
before it started actually organizing some
of that.
And so, an-and then, you know, you really
didn't even have moving, women moving into
these.
Being doctors and lawyers and judges and major,
very visible journalist's roles. All those
kind of things,
I mean, it's really new. It's really new.
And so we are on a steep learning curve, but
I uh, you know,
when you're trying to learn anything. The
faster you can cut that learning curve, you
know, the better
you get at something quick. And so that's
my book. That's and I guess I didn't mention,
and I should
mention the seven practices, right?
Should I mention what those uh, yea. I mentioned
that there's three generation, yea, oh yea,
let me
finish this and then maybe we can talk. You
know that there's, the book is divided into
the three parts
about: Part one being who we are. And I talked
about these three generations, kind of making
the
case about where we are and then the three
generations.
Part two is just two chapters and I call it
"Where-where are we?" And that's one of them
is called "Why
girls don't rule." and that's a whole discussion
of how women undermine ourselves, and how
we
undermine one another. And then there's a
very important chapter called, "What do men
have to do
with it?" The answer to that, of course, is
plenty. It's you know men can be tremendously
important
allies and they can also be blocks, you know.
So that's a very important chapter. I had
an incredible
father. I am one of seven children. I have
three brothers and three sisters. So I talk
about my brothers,
of course. And here I am also raising a son.
And I talk about him, of course. And so, you
know, the
whole role fathers and brothers and husbands
and bosses and colleagues, I mean, men are
very much
a part of this. So there's a whole chapter
about that.
And then the last half of the book, are these
Part three. I call it "How achievers become
leaders" in, that's these seven practices.
So, my seven practices are: the first one
is discover your purpose. Discover your purpose
and that's where you get your passion, and
that's where you get the energy because leading
is not easy. It's hard. So, you first have
got to find your purpose. And um-
The second one is "Raise your voice." You
know, we've talked to-for a couple of decades
about
women finding their voices. Uh, it's time
to raise our voices. And this, so that's the
next chapter.
Um, next one is "Break the rules." Of course,
you can't start breaking the rules until you've
mastered
the rules of the game in the first place.
But the leadership piece is having the courage
to break the
rules and knowing how to do it.
The fourth one is "Claim power."This is basically
about the fact that no one is going to give
you power. I
have this analogy that I use in my mind that
I say. Women are like these leadership wallflowers.
That
we are all dressed up, tapping our toes to
the music, hoping somebody's going to invite
us to the
leadership dance. And I basically say, you
know what, nobody's going to invite you to
the leadership
dance. You have to claim the power, and that
means run for office yourself. Go for those
jobs
yourself, but also women really need to encourage
other women to do that, too. We know that
it
takes women, there's plenty of research about
this, we know that it takes women about ten
years
longer than men to understand how good they
are. I want to cut those ten years, I mean
that's just,
come on. I want to get over that and start
figuring out earlier and start claiming power
and going for
those positions earlier.
The next one is "Drink at dangerous waters."
That's all about taking risks, but it's also
about getting out
of your comfort zone. And it's about, you
know, this whole global world that we're in
and developing
the skills to work really well with and recognize
talent in and build relationships with people
who think
differently from you, who are different from
you and it even means working with rivals
and people
you don't like. And it even talks about professional
enemies in there. So, "Drink at dangerous
waters"
is that one.
Then the last two are "Get back in the saddle,"
you can imagine what that's all about. That's
about
getting knocked down. Everybody gets knocked
down; everybody fails. I like to say, if you're
not
failing, I mean really failing, not just little
mistakes, I mean really failing. You have
no idea what your real
abilities are. And so you really have to fail,
and what differentiates people is how fast
they get up. How
fast they get up and get right back in there
and get back in the saddle.
And then the last one is- it's a word that
I coined and it's called "Womaninity." The
subtitle of that
chapter is "Beyond the girls and the guys."
But womaninity, I like to define womaninity
as um-
womaninity is to masculinity as Ms. is to
mister. Now all of you just kind of take the
word Ms. for
granted, but I remember very well when we
only had a choice of Miss or Misses. And-and
really it
defined a women immediately in terms of her
relationship to a man. It wasn't about just
you're a male
or a female as a man is just a mister. I mean
there is nothing about being married or single,
you know
or what? And so, the word Ms. came into usage,
and I know plenty of women my age who were
mocked in law schools, publically mocked in
their- in classrooms if they wanted to use
Ms. instead of
Miss to be identified. Uh so that was not
an easy thing, but now it's just common. But
it's very
important because it just basically defines
you as a female. And so there is no word that
is parallel to
masculinity, because femininity, when you
look that up in the dictionary it's really
all about the very
softest parts of women. And it even says it's
the opposite of masculinity. So, if we think
of masculine
meaning a man is strong, courageous; well
what's the opposite of that? Weak and fearful?
Femininity
does not work in terms of defining the qualities
of a fully evolved woman. And that's why I
came up
with womaninity, because I'm basically saying
that, you know, it's really time. When I started
learning
to lead and those kinds of things, pretty
much my only role models were men. There really
were not a
lot of women that I could look to, to pattern
myself after to see what worked. And a lot
of women my
age, you know, we made a lot of mistakes.
And we found out, you are- you're never going
to be able
to lead the way a man does. Because we're
not men, and so if you try to do that your
really going to be
criticized for it. It's not going to work.
And so we're really just developing this whole
enough examples
for us to look at. Uh okay, well how does
a woman, a fully evolved woman lead? And a
big piece of
that is being very, very comfortable in your
own- relaxed in your own skin, but also really
tapping into
the natural innate strengths of our gender.
And you know, we know, the two genders have
very
different, real strengths that we're learning
about our brains and differences between us
now. And so
that's what "Womaninity" is all about.
And then of course the Epilogue is really
just a call to action. It's just you know,
I really am
encouraging, trying to teach, pass along what
I've learned from my research experience,
and then
daring. I'm daring women to lead. So that's
my book.
So, I'd love any of your thoughts. I'd love
to have a conversation or any questions?
>>female #2: Are there any themes? You said
you talked to all these really powerful, successful
women.
Were there any commonalities between them?
You know, something that sort of, that they
all
seemed to have the same mindset or...
>>Ann: Yea, absolutely. And that was why when
you do 100 hours of transcripts and you start
looking
for themes. And that was how I, you know,
I finally came up with these seven practices,
because that
was really built on these themes. And I mean
and I actually started out with a list that
I also sent out to
several 100 women of just bullet points of
what I thought were qualities that maybe were
leadership
qualities. And I said, "Hey! Prioritize these,
what's missing from the list? Add things to
the list. Take
things off." And so all the women I interviewed
filled those out for me. But also, I had a
couple of
hundred more that also filled those out for
me. And then I just started cutting them up.
And seeing
how, which ones came up over and over and
over again. And I'd say, in answer to that
question, Lilly,
a couple of really most important things.
The biggest piece is confidence. I mean confidence,
confidence, confidence. It all comes down
to that and the faster we can get girls to
develop confidence at an early age and then
get them to keep
it through those really tough adolescent years
where girls tend to like loose it completely.
[laughter]
You're laughing because you remember maybe,
right?
[laughter]
Yea, uh- anything we can do to, that's that
piece about taking women, usually about 10
years longer than men to figure out truly
how good they are.
Um, and that's cultural. It's cultural muck
that, uh, women have to fight their way through.
And so
confidence is huge and another piece and so
confidence is related to courage. It's related
to raising
your voice. It's related to drinking at dangerous
waters. It's related to how you handle setbacks.
It's
related to every single one of these. Confidence,
that's almost like the clay, you know, the
building
material that you need. You can, it's the
fuel; I mean to say confidence is the fuel.
It's one of the most important ones.
The other thing that came up as a theme over
and over again was this whole issue of women
not
supporting other women, and women undermining
other women. And every single woman I
interviewed said something along these lines.
Oh, that's huge. That's huge. And in my speaking
that
I've done so far about this book, the most
questions that I get are about that, are about
that. And I
like to say uh- I use a great Madeline Albright
quote in here that-at beginning one of the
chapters that
says, "There's a special place in hell for
women who don't support other women."
[laughter]
I-I-I-I believe that now.
An-and I-I, you know, I mean I pretty much
divide women into two categories and I make
a decision
pretty quickly about it. When I meet somebody
I'm thinking, okay are you a women who supports
and
aligns with other women, or are you a woman
who separates yourself from and undermines
other
women? If you are in that second group, I
have no time for you. I have no time for you.
I don't care
what your job is. I don't care how much money
you have. You know, I don't trust you, and
I'm not
going to put any energy into sharing my network
with you. I'm certainly not going to follow
you as a
leader etcetera, etcetera.
And I want to make this clear for maybe men
who are watching this, you know, of what I'm
not saying.
Because somebody might say, well, gee, men
don't support one another. Well, yes they
do. And I
think that the language is different. Because
men understand very ear, no matter how competitive
they are with one another, men understand
very well that they need to align with one
another and
help one another. And what do you think the
good 'ole boy's network is all about anyway?
You know,
what do you think the Optimist and the Rotary
and the Lions and the Elks that women had
to sue in
order to get their way into those organizations
were all about? They're about men coming together
and-and helping one another and their networks.
Why is it that Augusta National Golf course,
where
no women are allowed to join and it's so prestigious
for CEOs to be members of that club. They
really
don't get to the club that much to play golf
there. It's about the network. It's about
them being part of
a network and having access to other very
powerful men. So, men absolutely do this,
and women
have not learned how to do this yet. And it's
very, very important, because I like to say
to women you
know what? You're never going to be one of
the guys. You are never going to be one of
the guys. And
you know, you need to get along well with
men, work well with men, support men, all
those kinds of
things, but you're still never going to be
one of the guys.
And so, your only natural other big group
for those kind of alliances is other women.
And women are starting to realize this and
there are starting to be networks of very
powerful women, who are at the top now. Who
have made a tremendous amount of money and
are starting to align together to help younger
women to get equity capital, to younger women
starting businesses, and things like that.
So, there are some things like this going
on, but it's really important for women to
stop undermining each other andstart understanding
that the only way we are going to make big
changes is if we recognize our
collective power.
And you know, other groups do this, and as
I said men have always done this in the professional
world.
Through all of history, men have done this,
but on top of that, I mean, you see Hispanic
organizations
joining together, you see African-American
organizations joining together, you see Muslim
organizations joining, you see many examples
of this. But women still, I mean, when we
begin to get it
in terms of how much influence we can have
collectively if we start thinking about that.
Um- we're gonna-we're gonna just leap frog
ahead.